what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation thank you so much for
being here I am about to watch a movie I
literally know nothing about but it has
been highly recommended if you like the
movie reactions here all you got to do
is comment leave down your request if uh
if I haven't seen it it goes on the list
and then I tend to go by like I don't
know I got a weird metric for what I
decided to do either way just leave your
leave your request down below I'm gonna
watch this movie called the bad guys
comes from Dreamworks and I have a
feeling I've been getting requested for
this because I covered Megamind recently
and I love that movie a lot I've heard
this is a good one uh it came out this
year and I haven't seen a trailer or
anything for it so I'm going in very
blind to this but I'm I'm trusting y'all
that this is gonna be honest if I don't
like it but trusting you guys on this
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated subscribe and click the
notification Bell in case we got
something that pops up on your feed from
us so you're like yeah that sounds like
a good thing to watch from them also
full-length Reaction watch along is
where you sync up with your own copy of
bad guys and more over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects cover a
whole bunch of stuff over there
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch along is included let's swing
into action and see what the heck the
bad guys is all about sea animals see a
wolf
awesome oh I'm an animal lover you might
see some cats walking by once in a while
in this video
[Music]
I don't need presents I don't want
decorations and I'm not a cake Guy
seriously though you don't like cake
name one food better than cake guinea
pig looks like Pulp Fiction now I know
the exact moment our friendship died
let's bounce yep these two voices are so
recognizable who are they
[Music]
oh
like Pulp Fiction is that intentional
he's also my best but today's his
birthday at relevant he's a sweetheart
you're a sweetheart he kind of sounds
like Sam Rockwell is this Sam Rockwell I
get so hung up on these movies I'm
trying to figure out the voices now and
over here is Miss tarantula our in-house
hacker our pocket search engine our
traveling Tech wizard we call her web
nice happy birthday Mr Grumpy pants I
think I hate you they're bad guys but
they're a family and this is Mr shark
Master of Disguise apex predator of a
thousand faces
Mr piranha
he's Brave
he's Fearless
uh who am I kidding he's crazy cool
animation
of course I didn't forget
you know you fart when you lie right
what no I fight when I'm nervous yeah
nervous about lying sorry
oh no eight legs
Aquafina that's who it is
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this like an action movie Jesus
foreign
[Music]
oh my goodness
the cake
the cake I really love the way the
streets are brought to life the hard
life streets
oh
my God look at him I've never liked a
snake more in my life take it oh yeah
yeah me please
sucker come on man now you gonna make me
get all aggressive
[Laughter]
okay I'm pretty sure the shark is Craig
Robinson these so-called bad guys are
really just second-rate husbands really
another bank is nothing but a deep well
of anger fine angry you're angry
and those are holes that no amount of
cash or Priceless are can ever fill
oh you were egging them on for tomorrow
night I will present the golden dolphin
to this year's goodest citizen
looks like they're gonna go after the
golden dolphin Now snake what better way
to wipe that smirk off the governor's
fuzzy face than stealing the golden
dolphin from right under her whiskers
you're in over your head wolf oh yes did
I not mention that that's weird I
thought I mentioned that it was
the Good Samaritan is a guinea pig
oh here we go so step one we'll need to
blend in
okay so this is like a heist movie first
can only be opened by a special key card
that is carried by our dear friend the
chief of police the second is outfitted
with a retinal scanner and guarded by an
elite special ops unit trained to strike
first and ask questions later
hahaha
interesting piece trashy pointless and
pretentious
they say that art reveals more about the
viewer than the artist Mr poodleton
Oliver poodle okay
smoothly Legacy there's cementing his
life in prison did you see their last
job unsecured exits crude disguises
compulsive showboating I mean it was a
mess
if you look closely enough even trash
can be recycled into something beautiful
God it's a swan I can't miss a photo op
with the governor in a pile of garbage
oh
I got that pretty late too
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's cool
[Music]
no that's okay no my biggest fear is the
snakes in the toilet
in case you didn't know that about me
it's a real fear of my thought that was
a snake for a second
dolphins
oh pardon me ah terribly sorry not a
problem sir keep your eyes open boys
terrible cops
[Music]
are you okay ma'am
I may be dizzy but I'm alive thanks to
you
kill her you're such a good boy
oh no
is he about to have an existential
crisis
oh no
no complete the heist first
oh God
[Music]
oh good yeah yeah
um get your head back in the game please
be subtle
[Music]
I'm having a baby
why go for subtlety my God that worked
so well
it's kind of like a zootopia heist movie
or something huh
[Music]
no way that would work in a movie with
talking animals I am questioning the
believability this is going surprisingly
[Music]
time to turn this baby on beast mode
it's kind of cool this award is
[Music]
[Applause]
disgusting come on
I'm starting to get mad here Larry
he's crying
[Music]
no don't pass out
is this the ladies room
oh uh you need to take a right at the
end of the hall ma'am
oh come on oh my God
the golden dolphin
no no please don't panic just stay calm
you're the worst Governor I did these
these things because of how they made me
feel
no
[Music]
and when you're good
you're laughed
shout out stop calling him wolf
bad guys with your hands up
run suckers
[Music]
[Laughter]
right now
whoa
no
the good in you got you in trouble
sadly we were never given a chance to be
anything more than second-rate criminals
if I can prove to everyone at that Gala
that the bad guys have changed will you
set them free and give them a clean
start no
what a crazy plan
hi Rupert marmalade IV will turn the bad
guys into the good guys I have a feeling
you might do all right we're gonna
pretend
to go good and then we roll into the
gala as good guys and roll out scot-free
with
the golden dolphin you guys you might
actually turn good
they say experience is the best teacher
and they are wrong I am cocky [ __ ]
it's not a butt it's a lamp in the shape
of the love crater meteorite my greatest
I wonder whose butt it is
once again
inside there's a flower the flower of
goodness and when it blooms and you feel
that tingle of positivity radiating
through your body you're going to want
to feel it all the time oh my God you're
conning your friends so you can be good
I'm going to give you a push pop right
to share why well on a fundamental level
it's about putting someone else's needs
ahead of your own ah great
nope sucker
I like Sharon it's yummy
totally worth it well that's terrifying
yeah look it's a cat stuck in a tree I
want you to
smack it get it stab it saute sing to it
save it
all right right
[Laughter]
oh that cat is obviously defected
Mark Maron that is an animal testing lab
within 200 000 helpless guinea pigs all
being poked and prodded oh God no snake
is gonna have a hell of a time here but
this is a place for good so I brought
something more friendly for you to wear
oh my God I hope they're bugged they're
kind of like the suicide squad hey there
Sirens Dad I know you've got an
important job
[Laughter]
I've been waiting my entire life for
this moment okay God damn
I got it
I've never seen him so chipper he's
gonna eat all the guinea pigs
oh
snake attack this is so bad just keep
your eyes blue to that door okay come on
snake open up
relax oh my God
oh my God
no spinning them out
20 seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not what it looks like no they're
telling he's telling the truth
I'm sorry Professor but I'm calling the
chief please come on
experiments you couldn't help yourself
so I had a moment of weakness sue me
it's gonna be difficult to do from
prison guys what do we do now you keep
the suits even if by some miracle we did
change who's gonna believe us huh of
course you wouldn't know anything about
that with your little miss perfect power
suits but you could form your own
identity man a wolf and a fox are not so
different
don't do it for them do it for you this
is a chance to write your own story oh
that's a nice message you don't have to
be the big bad wolf good soft wolf you
guys ever seen a baby wolf
it's so easy to spooky cat
come on Kitty come on Kitty
oh
this is so adorable
you you film that yes and they're
starting to like you you're really
getting it really oh thanks it's a shame
that you have to carry all that baggage
what you have great potential but at
some point you're going to have to
choose between your friends or the good
life
um
good life or John
the plan wherever to change you you tell
me right you have my my word
go bad
oh
you ever wonder what it'd be like
the world loving us instead of being
scared of us humor you ever think about
that I don't waste time thinking about
stuff that's never gonna happen uh I
can't wait for things to get back to
normal
my dude
don't become a self-fulfilling prophecy
put that energy out there you could find
a way to
be a good guy
you attract you know
you'd be good you attract good all night
will be on you tonight not me
friends mate the good guys
oh my God they're light
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at me
[Laughter]
oh my God
I have to say I'm a little disappointed
I was hoping you were gonna ask me to
dance
oh my God wolf
that kind of behavior will get you out
of office Fox how does it feel to have
everyone not fear you for a change
it feels good God damn it no this is
going to lead to some embarrassing
moments
damn how much money did there raise
that's a lot of money
professor
[Music]
do it a professor oh no
[Music]
Professor marmalade
chief that's not the plane what is
happening he's going rogue
he's going good it is a pleasure to
Grant the bad guys a full talk
the meteorite is gone
no
did this so long suckers
but they didn't do it oh my God is the
guinea pig really awful I was just
thinking there's no real villain in this
movie
there's some cool animation
I don't even know how to describe it
we're really good now he'll tell you
tonight's headline change is impossible
you should always judge a book by its
cover
[Laughter]
of course you didn't do it how could you
after all you're such a good boy we're
the legendary love Creator meteorite
will be on display for the first time
ever all eyes will be on you tonight not
me
there was his con
it's the ultimate power source you see
when it struck scientists found that it
emitted an electromagnetic frequency
unlike anything else on Earth okay he
fell for every one of my traps starting
with saving a helpless little old lady
what's he talking about
did I say too much you little Ginny
bastard that's not a racist but I'm
talking about an actual beginning
this is so upsetting I'm giving it all
back
[Music]
wow what raft is this don't want to be a
bad guy anymore huh and us your lifelong
friends we're just holding you back yeah
maybe you are
you don't sound like a good guy right
now wolf
[Music]
what
[Music]
is that the fox
oh cool
classic
nicely done wait a sec you're the
Crimson ball
oh my God stole the zimpango diamond
twice once for profit second time just
for fun never identified never caught
I guess I'm still the best bad guy the
world has ever seen I actually did not
see that coming at all
[Music]
this is a nice reveal
it's probably very predictable for
everyone else but me can't do it alone
you know his compound better than anyone
you can count on us
right guys guys
we're through wolf done finito is it
Mark Maron or Danny DeVito I cannot tell
when you grow up a snake nobody shows up
to your party out there I'm just a scary
good for nothing monster
but nothing compares to having the one
guy not one guy oh trust
stabbed me in the back
uh-huh that's sad
[Music]
there are times the animation has like
that motion of into the spider-verse a
little bit the action motion at least
okay
what do you saying we have some fun no
[Music]
let's try DC League of super best came
out this year there was an evil guinea
pig in there too
all I saw in the end was the tricky Fox
that they always told me I was
so now instead of hurting people I'm
helping them I'm still me oh I'm just
me on the right side
don't let others opinion of you define
you
[Music]
holy wow
because this stuff is nice too oh damn
what if you put the close to his lips
it's a joke
the greatest Heist the world's ever seen
that is brilliant we have to steal the
meteorite that was very cute yes as
though as it was
[Music]
wow that looks real
doesn't look like animation in times
uncanny
where is everything
[Music]
all right okay okay here here take it
what
he did something good
did you just do what my friend was sad I
was just cheering him up you
you did a good thing oh my God snake
ridiculous I just put your needs before
my own
I think wolf was right maybe we could be
more than just scary villains
oh my God they're all flopping
always be bad guys
damn he looks pretty scary when he's mad
[Music]
that's a mean con
[Music]
now we're back to another car chase why
would marmalade leave the golden dolphin
unprotected because maybe it's a trap or
maybe
but how did you know we'd even be here
oh I got a little tip from a friend
hey buddy how's it hanging what
horse and gas don't breathe
what is that that's not poisoned yes
sorry it's the piranha farts I can't
believe it's you you were right Wolfie
we felt the wag man it's good it's super
moving but can we do this later feels
like I got a Rhythm Section in my fin
guys am I happy to see you
oh look at all that love it's not
don't mind us just robbing this place
Oh I thought snake was in on it he
really did betray them
wow what a cool shot
I do like the way these action scenes
are are realized
later boys
dear Crimson paw you are something
yeah that's cool
oh she is so badass
nicely done it's like anime [ __ ] in this
okay
you keep that kid an extra safe I swear
the next move so it's my fault snake I
was hoping snake was in on the toll ruse
do you guys think they'll throw the
party yeah with
pinatas
y oh
go back for snake
we can't do this without
he might be a Mr Grumpy pants but he's
our Mr Grumpy pants great
[Music]
I'll give you one last chance to give me
the meteorite oh yeah what you gonna do
whiskers
this
that's a whole lot of guinea pigs
Ah that's kind of terrifying
there's some wild ass animation
thank you
[Music]
hey let's dial this down a notch huh
besides you'll never get him he's too
gonna drive her I know look how
excellent job he's doing maybe it would
be better to exploit his grace this week
exactly
exact
way
cat ham okay okay you win you can have
the space Rock good boy
I mean I feel like snake could have made
it
[Music]
oh I love how it actually came back
around you want him he's yours
snake
a reference to Metal Gear Solid in case
you guys don't know
[Music]
guys I know it's crazy but we're gonna
jump it crazy you're finally speaking my
language
you just probably killed some of those
guinea pigs by running your car into
them
I was afraid that if you knew I I wanted
to be good that you'd act like a jerk
and never talk to you again oh these
guys
I love you too buddy
oh do you know how beautiful this is you
guys
now you're gonna make me cry
[Laughter]
who said it was the end
wow that's a really long fall
what do they grapple onto
God damn the human strength on her
we're done running away yeah yeah yep
Chief do what you need to do what
but now she wouldn't want to
it's time we took some responsibility it
started clean slate
you finally did it this is your moment
Chief drink it in
wow you know I should I should give a
speech well I I should shouldn't I uh
that's not necessary
I'm proud of you wolf you know a fox and
a wolf are not that different you'd both
eat that cat he's bringing the meteorite
back huh
I guess yes springing bringing it back
that's precisely what I am doing
Dan that's a great microphone to pick
that up I have generously decided to
take the meteorite back to my compound
for safe keeping
oh you clever bastard this isn't the
media
what my friend was sad and I was just
cheering him up I think wolf was right
maybe we could be more than just scary
villains oh my God he wasn't bad
he didn't betray his friends
oh that's a great twist
[Music]
I had him switch it
[Music]
place
yes but that's a lamb where's that the
old switcheroo
[Music]
oh blew up the compound
[Music]
but
this was stolen by the Oh by the Crimson
Paw I'm a flowering goodness
that's my reptile right there
that's not what I'm talking about yeah
it was genius not only did I foil the
pig I got you to admit how much you care
about me sure yeah it did work
who do you think put that one push pop
in the fridge
ah
it's just twist upon twist here
we good baby
it at all
oh that was really adorable that was fun
all right all right well that was a cute
film indeed had a lot of fun with that
one a lot of uh pulling up the IMDb here
for the movie but yeah there was like a
couple little nods that are pretty it
catched her out that I'm not sure if I
set it out loud or not sometimes okay
sometimes when I since I'm editing and
I'm like I did say it out loud because
I often have these thoughts going
through my brain that I sometimes forget
to express because I'm also trying to
catch the dialogue and there was so much
whip fast dialogue here throughout
because it was like a fun
action-paced type of uh comedy here but
like they could say one thought I did
have that I definitely did not go into
was they they kept making the Clooney
reference which obviously is like
Ocean's 11 Clooney but then my mind
started trailing off even more of oh
that's funny because Sam Rockwell
starred in I believe the movie's called
Confessions of a dangerous mind uh and
that was a movie that I believe I might
have been George Clooney's directorial
debut uh directorial debut that might
have been his uh yeah it might have been
but anyway yeah George Clooney Sam
Rockwell they have indeed worked
together before uh
the bad guys uh yeah I thought it was a
really fun film that actually had a
really cool Vibrance about it you felt a
lot of influences in it throughout I
mean uh there was part of the animation
style that definitely reminded me of
spider-verse at times with the way the
the movement and the motion was in any
type of action scene I didn't have to be
like a big action set piece but even if
it was just running away from something
for a brief moment of time anything with
like actual movement there was this type
of uh spider-verse animation quality to
it but overall I mean I think it's like
a just a really solid family-friendly
movie like that I think it was hilarious
no no I wouldn't say that uh there were
some hilarious moments and there it was
a really funny film
and it's got a good message I think for
for the families out there for the kids
to walk away with you know one of my
favorite motivational speakers is Les
Brown and one thing
here's where I really test myself
I believe the quote that he often would
say is
don't let someone else's opinion of you
become your reality
and that's essentially what the theme is
of this you know like obviously dealing
with a lot of with uh beyond that Beyond
someone's opinion of you uh it it
exceeds that into
societal labeling uh is is one term for
it and I appreciate that they they deal
with that you know like a lot of times
you are dictated people is people can
the another term or self-fulfilling
prophecy is you know you you have a core
belief of who you what you might be who
you might be and then
through that through through the the
power of thought you can it's that kind
of thing where you can go let me try to
get my thoughts straight here for one
second I'm just kind of like rambling
through the power of your own beliefs
and it can be a very negative one you
can just land yourselves in situations
where you go see I told you I was right
um and that could often be something
when you say something like
self-fulfilling prophecy it can be
something that has a negative
association with it
essentially like with the law of
attraction you know uh you get what you
really truly feel and believe and these
guys this group of the bad guys uh by
you know what they've been dictated
towards internally their whole life they
have become that so I think for kids to
walk away and adults I mean adults are a
lot more in their own way because
they're adults they're not as their
brains are not as sponge heavy they have
become the the programming of childhood
that it it's it can be even harder to
break away from that mold because you
have formed a your I didn't expect to
like I'm trying to ride this line here
between going a little bit deep in my
thoughts and keep it in light but yeah
you know like uh we're often we often go
about our lives I believe uh based off
of uh how uh or our identity like what
we perceive our identity to be and and
we've at the end of the day we can
choose to form our own identity so I
think for kids to have this message is
is really valuable and important and I
you know I I know what it's like to be a
kid and watch something kind of goes in
one ear and out the other like oh it's
inspiring in the moment but then you
don't really do anything with it but I
think it is something that you can walk
away with I think it's a it's a real
pleasure it's based on a book huh
imagine it probably goes a little bit
deeper there but yeah to to have to have
that I think is is really nice and there
was there were Parts about the movie
itself that while I think everyone did a
great job with their voice over work
like to me the stand the standouts would
have to be
let me make sure I'm getting everyone
right here yeah Sam Rockwell is Wolf
there's something so natural about the
way he does it like he's he's perfectly
suited for a character like this and you
know a lot of times he does play like in
real life he can't play like the cool
Suave guy but sometimes he is playing
like a sleazy dude and this was the the
sleazy side of Sam Rockwell that is
charming and appealing and attractive
because he he knows how to play that
version too he knows how to play all
different layers of a sleazy guy and I I
think he did it really well like the the
Rhythm with his dialogue and the
chemistry that he forms with Mark Maron
snake there I got the the impression I
could be way off about this but it felt
like they were at least in the same
recording booth like characters like
aquafina's tarantula or shark I feel
like they could have recorded separately
but there was something about the
specific back and forth again could be
wrong about this could just be a great
handling of editing and Direction where
it felt like Sam Rockwell Marin at times
were in the same room together bouncing
off of each other so I thought they had
really great chemistry there zazi beats
as the fox character I thought was
awesome that felt like full spider verse
in that moment total Gwen Stacy uh when
you do reveal that she is the Crimson
fox or Crimson paw I I thought was a
really nicely done reveal that I'm sure
was predictable for others like yeah
it's predictable in the journey it goes
down who cares it's a little bit
predictable it's a little bit formulaic
I do not see Crimson paw coming but yeah
obviously the who who is the guinea pig
I don't know who that actor is and I
don't want Rich Richard iodine that
looks so familiar
I gotta figure out
what have I seen this guy from
he was zero in the Mandalorian the Droid
no I guess I haven't actually seen any
of the work that he's done
yeah
just looks very familiar I might have
seen his face when I found out that he
was playing zero on the Mandalorian
I thought he did a I thought he did a
great job too albeit a bit of a
predictable performance uh not
performance but a predictable character
reveal and there were times where I I've
kind of wanted the movie to
just slow down and settle in with a
change of beat you know because
sometimes it was it was moving at such a
fast pace and while I really enjoyed it
and had fun sometimes when certain
shifts would occur with the plot or a
plot reveal or a predicament that they
were in I felt they could have simbered
it a little bit longer like the one
choice that I thought they really
settled in with for a while was the
whole concept of snake and him not being
friends and I thought I had some really
good turns and reveals in the finale of
it and I thought that's what they really
settled in with uh in terms of that
choice but sometimes it felt like
something big might happen some type of
you know scenario might occur that
prevents itself a predicament or a
different type of plot development and
it would kind of just either get
resolved quickly or we're just moving
along really fast to the next thing and
there were times where I would kind of
wanted to to settle in a little bit more
with some of those uh some of those
emotions because when we got those
tender moments I thought this when the
movie was really singing a little bit uh
a little bit higher because yeah it is
such a Dreamworks animation movie with
the type of whip zaniness that it is and
and at the end of the day you know like
I I
I saw Megamind recently and and I was so
impressed by that and I'm more familiar
with Pixar films than I am with the
DreamWorks movies and Megamind I was so
impressed with and I don't I wasn't like
watching this comparing it to Megamind
thinking that it should be like Megamind
uh because it's a very different type of
film because they're drawing so much
from all kinds of heist movies like you
could see the Reservoir Dogs influences
you could see the Ocean's 11 influences
there are times where you kind of get
like heat influences
um you know the the Ocean's Eleven The
Pulp Fiction one at the very beginning
uh so it was a very different kind of
movie that they were doing and
I guess there are times I I would have
liked to settle in a little bit more
with you know who they are as characters
rather than just quirks especially with
the rest of the gang like if we just got
a little bit more beats with that
because they gave it to Wolf and snake
but didn't really get that sense with
shark or tarantula and and I felt like
the movie
it could have afforded a little bit of
like five minutes to just sort of
get invest in them as opposed to being
you know just funny characters or one
note characters and and I did find
myself craving that just a little bit
more uh especially because you know
they're calling this the bad guys and
they are part of the main Ensemble and I
felt like they never really got above
that one note I might be being critical
here just for the sake of being critical
because I'm in the review portion of
this video because it but I did find
myself actually at times kind of craving
that a little bit more often and yeah
other than that though I feel like this
as much as I ramble on about that it
really didn't bother me that much when I
was watching it because the the main
thing it set out to do was have a have a
nice message be really funny
entertaining have some impressive
animation and for a heist movie to have
this amount of like ridiculous turns and
reveals I really enjoy that I I thought
that was a nice surprise like especially
the reveals at the end with switching
the meter right around and then how a
wolf actually put the popsicle in the
freezer to show that he did see the good
in him the whole time it was clever I
would have liked to have been clued in a
little bit earlier uh just on my
personal level to to know kind of what
the
because it because I thought in the
first hour there were times it like the
first 40 minutes I would say where if
you're doing a heist movie or anything
with like these kind of criminals and
stuff you you one thing I think you
really got to sell are stakes and you
don't really
get a sense of what's really like okay
yeah they might go to jail but
before they
I you know what that might be it I think
I'll figure it out in the moment is that
when the heist actually began at the
beginning when they were first uh At the
Gala when you know wolf meets Fox
we weren't we didn't really get to know
the characters all that well other than
just the surface notes about them
and so I wasn't quite emotionally
invested in them yet and so by the time
we got to the actual plot of them doing
this you know bad guy turn good
Reformation so that way they could uh
pull up another Heist when they were
going there I think it was progressing
so fast that
you know I I would have liked just a tad
bit more of that extra feel of
of like oh no no you're you're you're
don't don't pull off that heist in front
of all those people wolf like now you're
turning you this is your chance to turn
good you know like a little bit more of
that conflict
could have just been that much more
palpable just like a tad inch it's like
a little bit of extra salt you know what
I mean
forgive me for not speaking clearly
right now I'm figuring out some of my
emotions as I'm talking about this one
of
the setbacks from time to time when you
talk about a movie immediately after
watching it uh and sometimes I'm sharp
sometimes I'm not but that uh that some
of some of this is like things I'm just
thinking about right now like it's one
of those things where in the immediate
moment I wasn't actually that bothered
by it
but in the in the reflection of it just
thinking about what could have made this
movie had that much more of an extra
punch of an emotional punch which would
have just further enhanced the the
comedy stuff and and the exciting action
Parts is having a little bit more of
that extra emotional punch and I really
feel like five more minutes just a
little bit spread out could have done
that just a little bit more
but it has a stance who gives a [ __ ]
honestly it's fun it's a fun family
movie at the end of the day it's a fun
family movie and it delivers like for
the audience at this movie's setting out
to do to to deliver for I think they
didn't I think they did an excellent job
and I could see why it's become uh a hit
did it do well at the box office why are
people suddenly talking about this movie
I I feel like this completely I didn't
hear about this until other people this
week started telling me about it I've
never heard of this movie till today
holy [ __ ]
248 million worldwide this movie did all
right
I've never heard of this
movie
kind of surprising to me
all right then
well there we are
I have talked about the bad guys I
enjoyed the bad guys uh it was a really
fun-filled animated action Heist film
thank you guys so much for being here
much love to everyone at the reject
Nation please feel free to show your
support feel free to contribute
hear my tour patreon page it's kind of
ironic to say it that way thank you so
much for being here and uh I'll talk
with you all soon
[Music]